God has a little child with him and he
says well what why are you angry and and
why why are you upset and Cain says and
God says if you do well won't you be
accepted and if you don't do well sin
lies at your door and unto thee shall be
his desire and thou shalt rule over him
okay that's a very mangled translation I
would say so I'm gonna take it apart so
what God says is while you're angry and
you're upset it's like well what's your
problem
and then God tells Cain if you did
things properly they would work out for
you well it's the last thing he wants to
hear because what Cain wants to believe
is that the reason he's not doing very
well is because there's no sense having
any faith in the logos the transcendent
is is evil and aimed exactly against him
and the entire social contract is faulty
that's what he wants to hear but that
isn't what God says God says wait a
minute maybe you're doing something
wrong well that's maybe a worse message
then everything else is corrupt it's
like you're having a problem because
you're just not everything you could be
well and then God says something really
nasty and you can't tell from this lines
I read a bunch of translations to try to
figure out exactly what it meant so this
is what God tells Cain he says you're in
a room in a house and there's something
at the door and he uses a metaphor God
uses a metaphor it's a sexually a lot
aroused predatory cat and you invite it
in you've invited it and you know that
it has evil intent you invited in to
mate with you right and you it's its
union with you this this malevolent
force this it's sexual union with you
has produced an offspring and that
offspring is what possesses you and so
not only have you done something wrong
you've you've invited the spirit of
wrongdoing into your life and you've
creatively intermingled it with it
voluntarily to bring forth a monster of
your own creation so that's what God
tells Cain it's like look it's bad
enough that God says you know you should
get your act together because maybe
that's why things aren't going so well
for you before you criticize the
transcendent
and the world and the structure of being
maybe you're doing something wrong but
it's worse than that he says not only
are you doing something wrong you bloody
well know you're doing something wrong
and you and you're doing it creatively
and with intent
so not only are things not going well
for you but you've played a creative
role in producing that situation and so
God basically says I am taking zero
responsibility for rejecting your
sacrifice it's all on you and so Kane
leaves and he's like seriously not happy
with that response because he wanted to
hear
pat pat you're a victim of circumstance
and everything is conspiring against you
and really being god I should get my act
together and just give you what you want
because obviously being God I'm wrong
and you're right well that isn't what
happens it's exactly the officer that
it's completely on you that's the that's
the judgment and so Cain leaves and
believe me he's he was Roth before it
his countenance had fallen before but
it's nothing like it is now and so he
hits the next stage and he thinks okay
I'm gonna take my revenge what am I
gonna do I'm gonna find the most
innocent and worthwhile thing that's
favorite of God and I'm gonna kill it
and that's what he does so it doesn't
matter that's his brother and Abel we
know we're drawing the inference Abel's
done the right things everyone likes him
everything's flourishing for Abel he's a
good guy he's one of those people that
you meet that has everything and then
you meet them and you wish you could
hate them but you can't because they're
really good people and then you really
hate them because not only do they have
everything but it appears that they
deserve it and there's nothing that sort
of sits in your soul and rots it more
than that realization and so that's the
situation with Cain and so Cain thinks
Cain talked with Abel his brother and it
came to pass when they were in the field
that Cain rose up against Abel his
brother and slew him so that's so
interesting because look look what
happens to Cain here so he's not doing
well he's separated from the
transcendent and from society
he's bitterly resentful and now he goes
out and kills the very thing that he
most wants to be so he destroys his own
ideal right he just demolishes his own
ideal that's how far his resentment has
pushed him and so he's he's
done right but he doesn't matter because
it didn't Able's him to take revenge so
he doesn't care it's like it's like the
the suicidal school shooter that blows
off his head at the end of his mayhem
it's like it doesn't matter to him it's
part of the same art form and the Lord
says unto Cain where is Abel thy brother
and Cain said I know I don't know am I
my brother's keeper well that's a good
question that's why it's posed in the
story cuz they answer that it's supposed
to be yes and God says what have you
done the voice of your brother's blood
cries unto me from the ground that's
actually the motif that Dostoyevsky
explores I would say in crime and
punishment because what happens is that
the Skolnick Cobb is Cain for all
intents and purposes and he commits a
murder but he gets away with it well so
he thinks so he thinks no one suspects
him he buries the money he can't stand
to touch the body he buries it in a in a
abandoned lot and he's drawn there now
and then to look at where it is but he
can't touch it because the money it's so
funny because the money before he kills
the pawnbroker is not the same as the
money after he kills the pawnbroker and
the risk onik off before he kills the
pawnbroker is not the same as the
Raskolnikov after he kills the
pawnbroker in fact they're not the same
at all and so the Skolnick olive is
tormented by God you could say but not
from the external world
he sets the crime up quite nicely it's
that this the spirit against which he
transgressed tortures him from within
and there's no escape from and so
eventually what happens in crime and
punishment is the Skolnick ov continues
to manifest himself as guilty in every
possible way until he receives the
punishment that he desires because it's
the only way that he can set things
right he actually he actually he
essentially turns himself in eventually
because he can't tolerate what he's done
so well so that's the idea the voice of
thy brother's blood cries unto me from
the ground it's guilt and now you're
cursed from the earth which has opened
her mouth to receive thy brother's blood
from thy hand
when you till the ground it will not
henceforth yield unto you
its strength a fugitive and a vagabond
shalt thou be in the earth you know when
you might say well why does God not just
strike Kain dead and the answer to that
perhaps is that wouldn't be sufficient
punishment that's what it looks like to
me it's like what's the punishment you
live with what you did right and I don't
want anybody taking you out either
because then you won't have to live with
what you did so that's the punishment
and Cain says unto the Lord my
punishment is greater than I can bear
it's like ya behold you have driven me
out this day from the face of the earth
and from thy face shall I be hid that's
the same as what happens to Adam in the
Garden of Eden
remember Adam hides from God and he has
his reasons
and now Cain is alienated from God
there's no Reid there's no
reconstructing that relationship he's
put himself by violating his contract
let's say with the transcendent and also
with society and also with his own
spirit he's put himself outside the
possibility of redemption and that's why
he says the punishment is greater than I
can bear there's no hope left right so
he's in hell for all intents and
purposes